- [Narrator] The year was 1996.
It was a different era, before memes,
before viral videos,
before anybody argued over
whether it's a giff or a jiff.
It's GIF, Jiff is peanut butter.
There was the dancing baby.
(upbeat instrumental music)
What is the dancing baby?
Who better to ask than its
father, Michael Girard?
- What are you doing here?
- [Narrator] The dancing baby, remember?
- Oh, the dancing baby.
Robert Lurye And I worked together
to design the animation.
The idea was to show that
movement could be programmed
and projected onto different characters.
- [Narrator] So Autodesk, the company
that Michael worked for,
started sending around the software
to other developers and animators.
It was just another demo
film until it landed
on the Lucas Arts server.
It was there that Ron Lussier tweaked
the original file,
converted it into a GIF,
and sent an email that would
change his life forever.
So we thought we should ask
Ron about his experience,
but Ron Lussier would
only talk for $30,000.
Every time the “you've got mail” voice rang.
- [Man] Welcome, you've got mail,
file's done, goodbye.
- [Narrator] It was another
goddamn dancing baby.
- Even I got an email of
the goddamn dancing baby.
- [Narrator] From that point
on, it was unstoppable.
Everywhere you looked
there was a dancing baby,
on television, on t-shirts,
on ties and commercials,
even boxers.
- Boxers?
- [Narrator] Yes Michael, boxers.
This all begs the question, what is it
about the dancing baby that
makes it so irresistible?
And what does it say about us?
- Have you heard of the uncanny valley?
It's a paradox where the more
a computer generated figure
resembles a human, the more
we become revolted by it.
- [Narrator] The dancing
baby is the uncanny valley.
- The dancing baby is the uncanny valley.
- [Narrator] It's been over two decades
since Girard and his team unleashed
their monstrosity on the world.
Does he regret it?
- Yes, 100%.
(upbeat instrumental music)